all right hello and welcome to an
introduction to emma lapse on google
cloud at next on air
i'm excited to share this overview with
you and i hope it will be super valuable
as you continue to leverage ai to
transform your business
first a quick introduction my name is
nate i'm a product manager on google
cloud's ai platform where
we have a mission to empower every
enterprise to transform their business
with ai
at google we've pioneered a huge range
of ai and machine learning breakthroughs
and much of this industry leading
technology underpins the products we
launch
within cloud ai but at the heart of our
product decision making is a focus on
the capabilities that will truly help
our customers
unlock new business value and so our
claudia platform does just that
by providing customer ai and ml teams
the infrastructure and tool set
to help them get more done more
efficiently and more effectively
let's take a quick look at the agenda
we'll start with the definition and
overview of mlaps and the core
challenges at play
we'll talk a bit about where data
science teams are today and where we see
them going
and i'll share a simple framework for ml
ops based on real processes that we see
in practice
both internally at google and from our
mature customers
and we'll wrap up with some of the
services you can leverage today to get
started
as well as where we're making additional
investments in the future that'll be
exciting to hear
so let's jump right in ml ops
formally defined might be described as
both a culture and a practice that aims
at unifying ml system development
and operations it takes both its name as
well as some of the core principles and
tooling
from devops and this makes sense as the
goals of mlaps and devops are
practically the same
to shorten the system's development
lifecycle and ensure high quality
software is continuously
developed delivered and maintained in
production
but machine learning has its own unique
challenges and different needs that
require special attention
and so let's jump to a slide that may be
familiar to many
which is from the canonical google paper
of 2015 hidden technical debt in machine
learning systems
the takeaway being that production
machine learning is more than training a
model
and that very little of properly
functioning ml systems
is actually model training code there
are a number of different technologies
and processes that must be in place to
get the most
out of production ml systems and it's
really this combination
and management of these different
processes that comprises true mlofs
a simple analogy might be the assembly
line
prior to the assembly line automobiles
had existed for decades
and even years before the model t ford
had something called the 999
which set the land speed record at over
90 miles an hour
but it really wasn't until the assembly
line was introduced which is
also just a set of technologies and
processes that continuous
high quality production and delivery of
automobiles became possible
and inexpensive and so at google
the cloud ai platform is quickly
becoming the assembly line for machine
learning
but let's take a look at where most
teams are now
most ml journeys will look something
like this
as a data scientist it starts hopefully
with
a clear ml use case and business
objective and with that use case at hand
you can start gathering data from
different data sources and doing some
exploratory
analysis that helps you get a sense for
what the data actually holds
once you have a sense for what's in the
data itself and you've you know imputed
some missing values
and normalized your data or done some
feature generation
you can actually start to approach the
modeling and figure out how you're going
to
tackle some new experiments and so you
would manually execute these different
experimental steps
doing more data preparation more feature
engineering and testing
and then you do some model training and
hyper primary tuning on any models or
model architectures that
are particularly promising last but not
least
you would be evaluating all these
generated models
testing them against holdout sets of
data that
wasn't trained on evaluating their
different metrics
looking at lost curve stability and
comparing those models with other models
to see which one
actually works the best and of course
this whole process is really iterative
and it's manually executed over and over
and over again
you might begin by doing multiple
different concurrent
experiments testing out different ideas
and different architectures
analyze and compare the performance
there and then kick off new experiments
based on what you learn
until eventually you actually iterate
towards an optimal model
and you'll be experimenting again there
with different hyper parameters
as you tune that final model until again
you get a model that is sufficiently
performant that it passes all of your
tests
and then of course unfortunately at this
step you put in storage and throw it
over the wall to the it and operations
folks and it'll actually be their job to
deploy the model to production as a
prediction service
and they'll ensure all the necessary
features are served in production
make sure we have auto scaling make sure
we set up any necessary deployment
pipelines for all of various targets
which
actually may be in a distributed system
and so it's easy to see why that process
is difficult
and why organizations are struggling
here first of all
it's really time consuming the steps are
highly manual and
are written from scratch for every use
case
it's also inflexible custom built steps
can't be reused
and are only understood by the author
and so every additional data scientist
in your team
or in your organization can't easily
leverage all the work
that a particular team member has done
towards their use case
and you know i hear from data scientists
all the time that
even they can't understand the work
they've done six months ago and leverage
that for the future
this is also an error-prone process you
get issues like training serving sku
where the lack of coordination between
it and
itops and the data science teams leads
to unexpected differences
in the online and offline performance
not only is this sub-optimal from a
performance standpoint but it's also
really hard to debug and figure out like
why that happened in short
there is a high marginal cost for model
development
and it really shouldn't have to be this
way
and so let's lay out a framework here
and start by
addressing some of the challenges we saw
using this framework across the ml
solution life cycle
and then we can dive into some of the
specifics and the details of each of
these steps
first in our first box on the left
experimentation is absolutely crucial
we don't want to hinder the experimental
process at all we want to lean into it
data science today is still very much
science
and for most use cases requires a lot of
trial and error
instead of cutting down on the number of
experiments we want a way to embrace
experimentation
let ml teams track and manage all our
different experiments they're running
to make sure they're confident in
building the best model
second re-running training jobs when new
data
is available or based on specific
triggers you might have set
ought to be really really easy we want a
continuous stream of new candidate
models to test
out and challenge the model running in
production to see if it actually is
better
third models must be properly tested
evaluated and approved for release
following a rigorous audible and even
reversible ci cd process
i think this step is really missed out
on by a lot of the data science teams
today
and lastly for any model running in
production you want to always have a
sense
of how that model is performing this is
important to ensure
quality and business continuity but it's
also crucial for
getting the high quality signals into
how to improve the model for the next
iteration what better training data is
there than
true production inferences
the dotted line the center here roughly
delineates
the training and serving sides of this
framework
and building a world-class mlaps team
and platform
is a journey and from a maturity
standpoint we tend to see
that customers find success by focusing
initially on the left-hand side of this
framework
the bedrock of ml ops is reliable and
repeatable training pipelines and so
as we go into the next section let's
take a look at
those repeatable and reliable training
pipelines
first we transform the previously manual
steps of ml experimentation into a
reusable pipeline
you implement an orchestrated experiment
of various steps
as a pipeline which can be executed
in its entirety in which it allows you
to iterate by changing some of the
configurations
to point to different data or use
different parameter values
and then you execute the entire run as
an experiment
and it's this repeatable and reusable
training pipeline
that lets you run multiple iterations
and actually produce different models to
compare
and though each pipeline here may
develop one or actually many models
the output of this process is not a
model to deploy
but rather the code of the pipelines and
its components
which is source controlled in a source
control repository
then similar to any software system you
set up a ccd
process for your code including building
components
running automated tests and tagging all
the produced artifacts
those produced artifacts like compiled
packages and container images
are stored in a central artifact store
and then the pipeline is deployed to a
target environment
this can be a test or dev environment a
pre-product staging environment
or a production environment depending on
the cacd trigger
if this is a production pipeline it is
executed automatically
and repetitively to continuously train
your model given new data
that can be either based on a schedule
like daily weekly we mentioned
or based on a specific trigger for
example the availability of new data
or drop in performance of the model
that's actually running in production
when a continuous training pipeline runs
till the end
it outputs a newly trained model and
that is stored in the central model
registry
for deployment as a prediction service
at some point in the future
crucially the link between the model
artifact itself
and the training pipeline is never
severed meaning that
all models in the model registry can
tell you their provenance
what pipeline trained them who created
the model
who ran the training job what data it
was trained on and evaluated on
and what were the metrics and results of
the different evaluations
this lineage tracking is incredibly key
as we'll see in the future
one additional thing to highlight here
you'll notice the parity between the dev
and experiment pipeline on the top row
here and the continuous production
pipeline on the bottom row here
avoiding the dev and production
inconsistency is
crucial as it's the source of many bugs
or under performance of models in
production is really hard to debug for
most teams
now that we have an overview of the
reliable and repeatable training
pipeline
which again is the foundational first
step of mlaps
let's take a look at the serving
pipeline
for deploying the train model we'll want
to execute model
serving as a csd process as well so
you'll fetch the model artifacts from
the model registry where our training
pipelines have actually stored them as
we just saw
along with the code that wraps the model
as a service for example as a rest api
to execute the following steps first
building the prediction service itself
then
running tests which may and probably
should be unique to your use case and
organization
and then deploying the service to the
target environment or environments
it's during this point in the process
where it's often advisable to run
additional tests
and add some release gates so for an
online serving use case
you may want to canary your model uh on
production hardware to ensure that it
meets certain latency requirements
you might actually also want to test out
different hardware
to make sure you're deploying the model
to the appropriately
optimal hardware for that model
architecture
in addition you might want to run
organized a b tests
to ensure that your new candidate model
truly outperforms the current model in
production before routing all of your
traffic to it
and so you might take one percent or
five percent of your traffic and
send it to the new model to test out how
it's performing on true production data
for that you'll also need to capture the
eventual business outcome
to serve as the ground truth in
evaluating that model's performance
when the model is deployed in the
serving infrastructure itself
it starts to serve predictions on live
data
and you can then enable explainability
and continuous evaluation where
the serving logs are captured and stored
for monitoring and analysis in the
future
we monitor model performance and
production to know if models are going
stale
to identify if there's any outliers or
if there's skew or concept drift
exhibited in the data
this would be something like the
statistical properties of the data
changing over time
which can trigger a new iteration of
model training or experimentation
and this happens all the time we know we
live in a dynamic world
and the data is constantly shifting
around underneath us
and so it's incredibly key to keep a
close watch
on the production data that's coming in
so we can identify
for example if a particular class is
seeing a shift in its underlying
distribution
again crucially because we have
maintained model provenance and lineage
like we mentioned
we can use a model's offline performance
as a baseline
when comparing against production and
quickly identify where concept drift has
occurred
as live data shifts away from the
training data
this also lets data science teams
quickly pull up the training data in
pipeline
to reproduce the run figure out where
the issue might be occurring
and then debug things
taking a step back and zooming out
here's the end-to-end view of both
training and serving using our mlops
framework and map to the input and
output artifacts
and different storage systems so we
start again with experimentation
development
where we develop a training pipeline
that is reusable and repeatable
and then the code is checked into a code
repository for source control
we then build that training pipeline and
deploy it to the target environment
either dev
staging or production using a ccd
process
where the artifacts are registered in a
central artifact repository
where we can pull out those artifacts
for deployment or roll back in the
future
now the model that the pipeline is
running in production
we can do continuous training either on
a weekly
or daily basis or when we have a
particular trigger based on the model
running in production
or new data is available the outputs of
these are stored in the model registry
which can be picked up for a model cicd
process
in the future that model ccd process
includes all of the tests stage gates
and approvals necessary
to rigorously make sure that the model
you're deploying to production is
ready and is actually outperforming the
model that is currently in production
and then crucially when that model is
actually running on
production hardware we want to make sure
that it's constantly
staying up to performance metrics and
that we can identify when it's starting
to decay over time
or whether there's skew or drift so we
can
go back to an earlier step in this
process retrain new models and deploy
them to production for testing
in addition this is a very complex and
high volume process
where customers may be running thousands
of different training experiments for a
single use case
and testing dozens of different models
in production at any given time
and it's important that we make sure we
get this full picture and make it
available to our teams
and so each of our pipelines and steps
in this mlaps process
writes out key executions and artifacts
to a central metadata store
where ml teams it leaders and governance
folks
have a system of record where they can
do analysis or
run an audit to keep track of these
myriad processes ongoing
as we automate the different steps of
our assembly line for machine learning
as shown here
okay now that we have this big picture
view and we put it all together
let's talk about ml ops on google
cloud's ai platform
discuss some of the products and
components that we offer to enable such
a system
and as mentioned the the claudia
platform really is our suite of
integrated products
for building and using ai and here we'll
just take a focus on
ops then we'll provide a bit more
context on the relevant
individual products themselves
so like before let's start with a team
that has existing data and products
and clear use cases they may be running
analyses and experiments locally
or in different siloed environments for
different organizations
this is kind of what data science looked
like in sometime around 2010
there's a lot of ad hoc analysis a lot
of custom tooling
a lot of different experiments run
locally not a lot of cloud usage laptops
stored a lot of the knowledge of data
scientists in the organization and when
they left the organization
that knowledge was largely lost
the first thing teams usually
standardize on from this original
view is the core data science platform
this would be things like which language
they should use which frameworks they'll
use
the preferred development environments
all the different things that most of
the team members will probably argue
about
in 2020 the average data science team at
most organizations has
a pretty good handle on this and though
there are many different options to
choose from and there are different
benefits and challenges associated with
those different options
and also there's a lot of low-hanging
fruit for improvement here
enterprises are still better positioned
than they were five years ago
from a core data science tooling
standpoint and model building standpoint
targeting back to our introductory
section in our framework
what most teams are now moving to build
is this true
production grade platform for mlaps
these are the services that enable the
end-to-end workflow that we saw before
following our mlaps ml ops framework
experimentation
continuous training model ci cd and
continuous monitoring
and so let's take a look at what this
looks like for specific gcp
products at the data science layer we
have our ai platform notebooks
which is a hosted jupiter lab
environment integrated with our
infrastructure
and various services you can
connect to a source control system run
notebooks in a scheduled manner and you
have control over the underlying compute
this is a familiar interface for data
scientists who like to do ad-hoc
development using
jupyter notebooks especially in the
upfront part of their prototyping
experimentation phrase
in the ml ops infrastructure layer we've
built this on modular services
backed largely by open source and mostly
by open source created by google
each of the boxes here can be used to
varying degrees
or not at all depending on your
different needs
based on many of the internal expertise
we have and
working with many of our customers we
know that ai workloads can be highly
customized
and so our services are designed for
novice intermediate and advanced machine
learning teams to use whatever they need
and also bring their own tools to the
platform as well
it's the core of this emmalops layer
lives our ai platform training and
prediction services
which are the backbone of building and
running models
the items in green are where we're
making our latest investments
a feature store to help solving train
help solve training serving skew issues
and improve collaboration within teams
by registering features during the
upfront training process you can ensure
that those same features are available
in production for your model at low
latency and you can also share those
features with
other team members to ensure that all
teams have access to the great work that
individual data scientists are doing
and make sure we're not duplicating
effort and we're using the most
powerful and effective features to build
new models
in addition a robust experiment tracking
service
to enable large-scale experimentation
the ml the ml
model introspection use case and
comparison
incorporating great google open source
products like tensorboard
this is also really critical because the
amount of experiments we run
is directly proportional to how
confident we are that we've really
chosen the best model
and by making experiments shareable and
easily referenceable in the future
we can then enable other members of our
team working on the same or similar use
cases to learn from the work that we've
done
in generating the optimal model for our
use case
at the bottom layer there we have our ml
pipelines
and centralized metadata store for
orchestrated managed end-to-end
workflows
these are really critical for building
this end-to-end capability and making
sure
we're not writing custom code for
different steps of
this this end-to-end process that can't
be leveraged and reused in the future
you want to make sure we're
orchestrating full runs of end-to-end
pipelines
and tracking the outputs of each step
the inputs and outputs of each step
in our central metadata store and for
many of these different items in green
we offer great open source and hosted
solutions today
and we're working on bringing managed
services to these areas
in 2020 and so
what's shown here is simply the high
level overview focused on our mlops
stack
definitely stay tuned for announcements
in these investment areas and more as
our platform grows in breadth
and depth and so with that
i'll leave you with this view of our
mlops platform
your teams can begin leveraging the
power of ml ops on gcp immediately
by checking out our ai platform in the
gcp console
for more information i've included some
detailed blogs and solution guides for
further reading
which are the best place to start here
and they'll be published alongside this
breakout session
after reading these please reach out to
google cloud rep to get in touch
we would absolutely love to hear from
you
we'll also be answering your questions
in the dory throughout the next week or
so
i thank you for tuning in and listening
and we are immensely excited to see what
you build with our cloud ai platform
thank you